おはようございます
わー
本日
光ドロップを担当させていただきます weather ですよろしくお願いします
移動ぷたんとおったかぽんですよろしくお願いしますリストラップ担当
アオシマですよろしくお願いします木ドロップタント玉沢ですよろしくお願いします
闇ドロップタントでばあちゃんですよろしくお願います
本日のお乳孔が
私光ドロップ担当が好きなせていただきます
宜しくお願いしますガー
我々が今回落とすドロップはアキュラに置いてあります
[音楽]
我々
1今後で儲け
落ちここで
コンボを繋げていきましょう
はーい
先に数え
分
はぁんっ
たばいばーい
馬場わー
目 j
うん
さっけれどやませんぐわぁ
貼っニャー
いや宿題1週間忘れただけでも学校くんなんて舐めてるのか
パズルを救う
あ
前集合 y
大変です早速プレイヤーパズルを始めました皆さんは落ち込んの準備にかかって
ください
はあああっ
ぶーぶーっ
をゼロ the one じゃーんを
wiiu 舌を出す意向と
始まったぞ
バッハ
ano ん
me
[音楽]
水野分02日目はいっ
水こいうそー
rar シャア
いやべき落ち込むきたなぁ
#ルツいくぜ
もうあたりすぐ遊びましてはここ
がんばれがんばれん
ああああああああ
あれ姉ふふっ
ん
こちらもちろん運
th
ほっほ2個つながってるところがないまずい
m 0分左が2341了解しました
[音楽]
まだいける次男分左差別ねーおい
visions 肺機能って入っ
4バッドばつで組んだよな知浩
[拍手]
カンセンジャーバトルずリークぜバブツリーですよ
4つの
あれあれフ
阿部止められ開封4鈴鹿伊勢へ
もちろん skype ワイ二回じゃ開封台北
タイプでしょカクカク取られたくない回復今日休みです her a
el ぎゃん
me
ああああああっはーこ
彼らわー
あぁぁああああああっあぁああああ
まず旅行レジャー
キックぜ
マルチ御宿の早いでしょここからです
入れ
はいはいべを超呼びなるので音止め
菖蒲闇闇を誓うただちゃーん遠藤マフラー
ヒラリーチェックねー第10回バイ
はぁん
ん
ああああああ
うーん
[音楽]
ni nare
知らない土地は前傾あなたは製剤ですか
素晴らしい版と言いますよ今に入れるとアッシャー
これ池先生情報によれば次がある
ラスト待ってないん
ジェスです
予防フラストやべうちルーツだ
やって俺パソナやフェイスな
はやっぱ
ただ頑張ってくれああ
紅ん
あっああいうえうえで父がペレッ
やめやめは魔女であれ前
あ良い読みだじゃないかぁぁぁぁ
ああああああ
ああああああん
ふざけんなああああああああああ
arere
なんねだぁーっこっちよねっは
られがてなんだああ
パターン
課金していいーしっかりしないわわー
ありえもうちょいちょんっああっ
ああああああ
書入りましたらああ
ああああああああ
ああああああ
[拍手]
1ポインティングぐらいのいっしょばす欠けがありましたわー
綺麗ですわぁこれでねサーサーん
これ絶対治す
はやべやべえ
ダメ
みんな hey ハーイ水が右にずれてねはい
キロ右さん出てきたからにません r
みたいに厳重ぞ
バーンバーン
[音楽]
アークさぁい
[拍手]
ana ああああ
[音楽]